welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and as the mcu descends into a
multiverse of madness pinpointing the
culprit who triggered this shattering of
reality is getting more and more
difficult okay who broke the fabric of
existence someone's gonna clean this up
like we saw reality warped in avengers
end game and then again in one division
and then again and loki and then what if
and eternals and no way home and now i
kind of feel like that guy watching the
fireworks show and saying okay now this
is a finale i don't know it's just some
sparkly ones
okay now this has got to be it oh no no
no how long is this fireworks show we've
been here birthdays everything's on fire
so identifying the primary perpetrator
most responsible for rupturing the dam
of the mcu multiverse will tell us which
character this multiversal crisis will
revolve around and whose madness must be
cured to settle it like a great agatha
christie mystery i submit to you 12
suspects as i answer the question of who
broke the multiverse suspect one wanda
maximoff wanda was confirmed as a nexus
being with powers that exceed that of
the sorcerer supreme now using chaos
magic to orbit spherical representations
of universes around herself hearing the
voices of her sons calling to her from
another dimension with her confirmed
return in multiverse of madness as a
possible villain and assuming marvel
studios is adapting a house of m event
wanda certainly is our number one
suspect having both the means and the
motive to go full on carry on the mcu
but rewinding the clock to a few years
to the suspect who took everything from
wanda suspect number two thanos not only
did thanos arguably send wanda on her
warpath the guy snapped all the infinity
stones twice one to dust away half of
all life again to destroy the stones
we're still learning about the full
effect of those radiation shock waves
including the emergence of the
celestials and eternals and i suspect
that thanos as an eternal with a deviant
gene is linked directly to the
celestial's big plan but since one of
those stones governed reality in the
universe it is possible that atomizing
that stone left this universe as fragile
as my knees are when thanos strikes the
right pose similarly suspect number
three bruce banner banner snapped the
stones to bring back the dusted but did
so in a chaotic way that most directly
seems to have triggered the celestials
but the moment hulk snapped notice his
body was coded in a red outline for one
frame suggesting reality was being
rewritten around him and now his own
nature seems to be glitching as he is
inexplicably reverted to a variant human
form suspect number four tony stark
stark's fateful sacrifice play was the
most recent blast of cosmic radiation to
warp this universe one oddly narrowly
tailored to dust just thanos in his army
but nakamura whom stark had two minutes
in the fog of war to learn this
character he never met switch loyalties
okay but could stark have been
permanently cursed by wanda's chaos
magic back in age of ultron to align the
universe in a specific way that wanda's
inner destined scarlet witch foretold i
mean everything else bad in the mcu is
iron man's fault so why not this suspect
number four steve rogers despite
restoring the broken sacred timeline by
returning each of the infinity stones
rogers nonetheless created a variance
according to loki's director by staying
in 1949 with peggy carter that should
have made him a target for pruning by
the tva but suspiciously the man walks
scot free by appearing at the end of end
game to give sam the shield so he got
away with it is this old man survival
evidence itself of a multiverse already
broken i hope that dance with peggy was
worth it suspects number six loki and
sylvie now i combine these two loki
variants into one because i believe only
together did they create a nexus event
so raging and throbbing that it burst
through the apocalypse that was supposed
to cold shower it i believe it was that
moment that began the chain reaction of
the sacred timeline's unraveling not
sylvie stabbing he remains since we saw
the timeline fracturing several minutes
before he died but that brings us to
suspect seven kang the conqueror because
the true plan of the council of kangs
may have been to manipulate these two
loki variants into a relationship in
order to create that chain reaction of
chaos that would inevitably knock the
multiverse so off the rails that a kang
prime could rule openly as a fascist
conqueror once more because in an
orderly segregated universe kang must
hide behind the curtain but in a broken
messy multiverse kang is king suspect
number 8 doctor strange in the no way
home trailer strange helps peter parker
try to gaslight society via magic
despite wong's warnings a spell that
misfires and breaks the rules of well
movies strange must have either agreed
to conjure this dangerous spell knowing
what it could do or in a desperate
attempt to fix a multiverse already
broken but either way this doctor is
liable for metaphysical malpractice now
often when i'm watching a movie or tv
show i'm furiously scribbling notes and
pausing to catch all the details but
when i'm watching something not for work
i like to sit back and enjoy a nice
glass of wine while i just you know
relax and enjoy i am capable of doing
that but when it comes to advice on
which wine i should drink i like to lean
on our friends at bright sellers thanks
to brightsellers for sponsoring this
video brightsellers uses a quiz to
determine your taste preferences and
then they show you a list of the top 6
wines that you are most likely to enjoy
from around the world and if you like
your recommendations and want to try
them they will ship them straight to
your door they educate you about wine
along the way with their wine education
cards that have helpful info like tasty
notes and alcohol percentage behold the
bright cellar wine box i got this month
wine
this one is called a folk and fable
already jammy and spicy this zinfandel
spends three months aging in bourbon
barrels got strawberry blackberry baking
spices and black pepper mmm yum yum yum
they also have a white one it's called
me cute stone fruits like peaches
nectarines and apricots dominate the
flavors of this sweet white i've
received a bunch of boxes from bright
cellars over the past year and based on
my feedback they always adjust the wines
that they send me it's just a really fun
thing to open up every month and bright
sellers is giving our followers 50 off
their six bottle box and the first 100
people to check out will get a free
corkscrew so follow the link and take
the quiz and get started suspect number
nine peter parker now peter is the one
who tampered with the spell upon getting
second thoughts about erasing the
memories of his loved ones and since the
spell seems to use a strand of his hair
to function the way the spell breaks
might use peter's soul as the nexus
point upon which the multiverse flips
which is why the people who cross over
are the people linked to spider-man his
enemies or maybe even variant peter
parker's peter's intentions may have
been innocent but he is still the bart
simpson of this crusty sketch
i didn't do it
suspect number 10 chung chi now this guy
used the ten rings to slay the dweller
in darkness a being from another
dimension which according to wong was
the moment that beacon inside the rings
began pulsing summoning something
probably to alert that multiversal
threat that the multiversal demon that
buffered this reality from the next has
been removed making it open season now
for every other demon with a taste for
souls nice going shuchi suspect number
11 strange supreme episode four of what
if showed an alternate reality stephen
strange absorbing countless demons from
other dimensions to carelessly bypass an
absolute point in the timeline allowing
all of reality to melt into nasty nasty
cosmic dark matter sludge strange
supreme is confirmed to return in a
future episode meaning his actions may
have future consequences to the broader
mcu either way this guy's gotta pay for
what he did the cloak of limitation
however
suspect number 12 uatu the watcher
definitely bears some responsibility
because strange supreme one could argue
was too blinded by love to see the full
weight of his actions but it was the
watcher's refusal to intervene that
continually leads to multiple realities
premature deaths melting into ink
overtaken by ego or zombie could the
inevitable multiverse collision that we
are on the brink of be the result of
uwatu finally caving and intervening in
ways that he shouldn't so again we have
it 12 suspects some with more inky
multiverse blood on their hands than
others but each guilty at least a bit of
breaking the multiverse beyond repair in
their own right but they cannot all be
the nexus event that broke the
multiverse can they well folks that is
where we find ourselves back on the
orient express because all 12 of these
suspects are equally guilty we got 12
angry jurors judges and executioners who
each put a crack in the multiverse damn
with their own unique signature the
multiverse was already on the thinnest
device thanks to kang's repeated
meddling branches inconsistently patched
allowing loose ends like the one cap is
on ice broken by the loki variants
opening a window for the scarlet witch
to mix realities wanda herself being cut
off by the actions of thanos and banner
and stark following a voice that might
have been the same voice as the one
who's now following a dinner bell in
shanghai all while doctor strange and
peter parker and the other doctor
strange try to play god and uwatu not
being enough of a god death by 12 cuts
that created this perfect storm that we
now find ourselves in and therefore i
don't think the multiverse of madness
will simply be a not for any one
character to undo but something that
will require the efforts of every mcu
character to confront in their own way
but uh all this said i mean yeah it was
totally doctor strange who broke it
right like both him and his bizarro self
ignored wong crossed a line and then
pointed a finger it's not peter or
uatu's fault it's yours steven strange
and that's why you are the one in the
multiverse of madness on that movie's
title card let me know in the comments
who you think is the most responsible
for breaking the multiverse support new
rockstars by checking out our merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter at ea follow
and subscribe to new rockstars thank you
for watching and i rest my case
[Music]
you